okay so we're we're going now
do you hate this podcast don't hate the
Vargas no I hate your co-host no I hate
what like is usually like you know we'll
get ready to do it and then like you're
you're overwhelmed with things to do and
then you get it and then you hate me and
I just didn't in it you know I just
basically spend the podcast like this I
feel you girl daddy yeah you be spread
like yeah you you made you insinuated
this baby cryin it's my fault
like I didn't do it but everything that
is wrong in the world ISM is my fault
I'm sure no other man has ever
experienced this and well last night you
are on the pka podcasts for how many
hours guys on there for 6:30
like midnight 11:00 we got down to 11
okay in the in those lorna half four and
a half hours not once did you mention
our podcast you were on a podcast and he
didn't mention your own podcast
I don't self promote well I and I I got
my my assistant who was also some papers
to like before she went upstairs to I
have things that yeah I should remember
to plug oh yes because the PKA podcast
is also on YouTube so I gave you the
link to your caplets youtube.com
backslash Kappa Rollo caplets because I
knew you didn't know the exact link yeah
cuz I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] Anna okay the
tour dates cuz I knew you didn't exactly
know your tour I didn't think I'd had to
say hey tell podcast listeners that you
have a podcast see the sorry's like a
half-hour jotted it down John saying
that that you're like you know
I was just yelling at you because
because it's really me I did you know I
knew because you knew you [ __ ] up by
not putting that on but like the things
live the things to promote and but now
it's back to I'm a dick the mics are
rolling then everything's get on so it's
like alright and we're on the air Jon's
a dick so great you're right it's my
fault for not reminding you to wipe your
own ass or to tie your shoes or to
breathe oxygen no now I'm just gone too
far
yeah it really is just like you dig that
hole so yeah
Happy Thanksgiving yeah we should he
invited the Indians um we have it's a
Thanksgiving day that we're recording
this I am thankful for you it sounds
like I am thankful for this teething
crying baby yes I am I am certainly
thankful for uh for you and everything
that has come into my life as a result
of you which is that teething crying
baby and this Fogle and just a lot of uh
just a lot yeah whether it's just my
life would be awesomeness you're looking
for the word monument it wouldn't be
nearly as good a place even though I you
know I can consistently complain about
my life but it wouldn't be where it's at
without you I wouldn't be sitting next
to a crying baby but I'm trying to do a
podcast if it weren't for you I you know
I used to hate that on planes but now I
have it at home
when
trying to do a [ __ ] podcast on
Thanksgiving [ __ ] day it's a holiday
I had a crying baby next to me Jesus
Sweet Pea I'm sorry
frozen washcloths no is it losing its
frozen this pretty hard yeah you just
just Church I'm sorry you want to be a
sick pervert you can she's talking it's
oh good start you know no I don't like
that I don't want to be a sick pervert
she's she's my daughter and I want her
teeth to you know not hurt it would be
good
hey Decco
I didn't feel that how you felt them
come in now and you said that the other
day I didn't yeah you can see him a
little bit and she's wearing one of
those amber necklaces things it's
definitely Jade never heard of it until
you told me about it I went to a Native
American store like last week or
whatever and they said amber is like
what is it gone oh not abundant in
danger no it's an animal well I didn't
know if it was endangered like it's the
same thing it's an endangered species Oh
like where it's like oh it's uh I'm
sorry that I don't know the words
we'd be um it's it's uh yeah yeah none
of not abundant is fine yeah we'll go
with that not an easily accessed
resource
I don't know I'm stupid so I just back
up being your thesaurus for this one but
then I found the necklace at Babies R Us
and so I'm guessing it's probably just
[ __ ] plastic who knows well it's all
over yeah a simple Native American shop
may not have access to thee know that
abundance of
um aunt real amber that [ __ ]
toys-r-us desert well babies arson oh no
it was byebye baby all that changes
everything
I mean it's ya know you I haven't I mean
I usually keep up on the amber market
but for some reason I'm slippin in that
word in the amber what they do the
mosquitoes in Jurassic Park were like
yeah yeah I know my Nana has like um she
has a bunch of jewelry and she has like
rings and necklaces and bracelets and
stuff that have amber with like
mosquitoes and bugs in it like
prehistoric caught bug know several ways
to keep it in a necklace
why is cool why would some of my
favorite take the DNA head of it and
start [ __ ] amusement park
I don't know cuz it was probably caught
last year I mean who knows
oh you mean it was caught in the amber
it's all a hoax bugs weren't from
dinosaur era they just tell you yeah who
knows yeah this this mosquito died in
1964 Oh are we getting out of that
nothing you is so uh who yes I did that
podcast last night yeah that's a long
time to talk to some dudes you don't
know they said they reached out to me
with like statistics and like they
sounded legit yeah and stay and so I was
like looking through their stuff and I
noticed that they were really long but
I'm like how long do you want for him
for an interview cuz like ten minutes is
a long time for an interview usually
when they go especially when it's over
cuz it was over Skype and you know with
Skype you you really notice when you're
you're telling jokes or you're trying to
or you're just saying anything that's
funny like you know whether it's
to remark or something like that it like
there's a there's a yours have to like
wait an extra beat for there to be any
reaction so it's like it's it you almost
like you feel like you're bombing for a
second and then there's a laugh and then
you're like oh good okay alright good
all right let's let's keep going it's
like you're doing myself to live another
day yeah but it's just you're just good
I mean you know you'd think that Skype
would make things I mean I guess it does
make things easier as opposed to the
phone um you know yeah you at least were
able to like see the reactions and
suffering but but the thing is that what
I'm saying like when you're you when
you're saying things that are you're
just - I mean I don't know these guys so
I just it's just sort of like I
generally make more funny remarks or or
or attempts at funny remarks when I
don't know people cuz it's usually just
it's an instinctual thing because it's
like it's out so I sort of you know
break the ice and you know when you
don't when you have that sort of hiccup
with uh with the you know basically a
phone conversation it's uh there's just
as yeah I mean I used to hate I always
hated like I'm glad that like talking on
the phone is pretty much it's almost
extinct like it's it's not it's not
abundant anymore it's on the endangered
list it's because I always hated the you
know I mean there was just I remember
you know my sister like when we were
kids like she just so desperately wanted
it a phone in a room and my parents
agreed to like give her like a cordless
phone but it would like the base would
be kept in their room so it wouldn't be
like she could have her own phone you
know it was just such a big deal right
you know back then and then uh you know
I mean it's just the concept of like it
you know like if you got a girl's number
you
couldn't you think you couldn't text her
and just go hey what's that you remember
me yeah I like her like I did with I
mean I texted you when I got your number
is like it you know calling somebody is
so potentially mortifying you know
you're just like I hey hi it's Jeff John
John remember the guy you get he gave
you know you were pretty drunk I guess
boy um I feel like [ __ ] but anyway I won
see he won't hang out ourselves and it's
like I mean or you would I remember like
in high school be like you know just
calling girls to talk almost like as a
as a you know as a precursor date
Facebook or anything like that like you
couldn't be on a chat room with people
so hey I am was huge when I was in high
school
AOL Instant Messenger right yeah see I
my name was my maiden name is Kelly so
Jamie Murray Kelly but backwards so it
was why ll EK e I are am we know yeah
Kelly backwards
alright what was your name really I
never would I was never on I used to
hear about chat rooms but I was never on
chat room cuz it was like it was
basically like Twitter Instagram blue I
mean it was the start of all that it was
your friends right but see it's like
okay so you know AI M is like it's
almost it's like instant emails also
essentially right like if you're on the
computer at that time Oh remember a way
messages of course you don't cuz no I
heard you're no fun
I know okay congratulations on your
marriage
surprised I know I'm they're leaving
like the perfect away message was so big
and mine were always song lyrics cuz I
was that girl uh-huh
yeah you still are I don't leave salt
like some girls some ladies leave not
Instagram them its Instagram like you
don't know Instagram either [ __ ] what I
I know what it is I mean I understand
like music quotes I don't do that yeah
it's well i-i've seen Devin even like I
was thought there was certain people
like I know who like would be they put
like song lyrics as you know like my
nephew doesn't mind if you do that it
with the put song lyrics on the end of
his text messages or whatever you know
like and I never understood what they
meant you know it'd be you know like
he'd send me a text and at the end every
text it'd be you know like you know no I
don't know Jenna be like Heil the dragon
or something they'd be like what wait
what was that at the end he was just
it's it sent me a text about yeah I mean
I was coming into your Clevelanders RAL
the dragon er they were quite it's you
know what it was you saw I showed you
what it was asking you what it was at
the time punk ass he's throwing me under
the bus like no I don't know what you're
saying and quit what look we have a baby
you have a baby I don't know what you're
saying what does this baby have to do
with anything
I it's about you throwing me under the
bus about hey stuff that you should know
about anyway Happy Thanksgiving
yeah be Thanksgiving um what did you do
for things giving growing up hmm
Thanksgiving was uh you know I usually
like Thanksgiving of all the holidays
because it was very very relaxed we
didn't do anything what well it's just
very like there was no um
I mean obviously there's no like gift
buying and gift exchange which I hate
but there's uh there there was no nobody
was coming over
nobody was you know we weren't going
anywhere
it it was just I had you know four days
off the school and you know that you
know Thursday would you you know be just
football and food and and and in bed
it's my least favorite holiday because
it's so stressful really yeah you have
to clean and cook and there's no
presents it's like the opposite of what
you like you don't get any reward I I'm
sorry I thought that was cute we're on
skype actually being her was a delay
between that my joke and her laugh it's
uh but yeah I I had the exact opposite
experience as far as I go suppose
because I mean you know gene would make
a turkey usually up until you know she
had maybe told you you know like later
when when we got you know when we got
maybe into high school and she was or I
was in high school my sister was in
college and she just didn't feel like
working that hard in the kitchen and she
really you know but she just make you
know like it were come on in we're gonna
cut the pizza you know like Matrimonial
cutting of the people yeah it's a
ceremonial this is what you want
matrimony is a wedding go [ __ ] yourself
the sorriest [ __ ]
it's crazy the matrimonial reason I it
but they I we just would it was really
simple we just always had a very simple
Thanksgiving dinner that involved just
yummy
my parents my sister
later on we'll be my sisters you know
boyfriend or whatever would come over
but you know and then of course all my
girlfriend's you know so yes I would
bring my hand to dinner but yeah it was
just um it was easy you know as opposed
to you know like Christmas when it's
always like you know well you gotta go
do you know this place for Christmas Eve
and then we get it then Christmas Day
there so and so it's coming over and
then we got to go over the year um you
know Christmas Day and I it was like
always there was so much like you know
you had to do so much on Christmas there
it was just such a hassle there were so
many appointments and I didn't
I don't like appointments mm-hmm so
anyway we're gonna take a commercial
break we which is funny because we don't
have any sponsors we'll be right back
yeah yeah just because you hate holidays
so much like every remember that one
year that I cried on Christmas just
sitting or crying and the boys were
wearing sweaters I know that's the worst
you just [ __ ] dogs and sweaters hear
crying that's a good way I mean it
reminds you it's like it's not like we
we have nothing to eat or something I
mean there's a pool out in the backyard
I think Jesus get it together dude
I mean and I just you know I
I'm not we didn't have obviously we
didn't have Madden at the time we didn't
have it was just a really a time when it
was you know I get off the usually it's
probably like that this year it's like I
get off the road and I sort of have a a
clip of time at the end of December or
whatever going into January where I
don't have to go on the road or do
anything and I don't deal with [ __ ] so
it's just like yeah let's just yeah I
just want to hang out or be a [ __ ]
hermit and that obviously you know to
you would would be I guess depressing
when it gets to and it depresses me to
depress you because I don't want you to
be you know I want you to be unhappy at
all
I I just you know but when it gets to
that day like when it's supposed to be
Christmas Day or whatever Thanksgiving
day like today when we're just hanging
out just us today you're okay with it
today but I mean to a degree I don't
think you like me as your holiday yeah
right
that's not a special occasion with
Thanksgiving okay so we had friends over
one year we went over to friend's house
one year Christmas we've never really
celebrated I put up the tree and stuff
one year and that was the year I cried
because you like refused to come
downstairs for anything but you've never
celebrated holidays so I've adapted
myself to you
so with getting mad and ready for her
first Christmas I just assumed that one
day when my mom was here my mom stayed
with us for the past two and a half
weeks so building a case on me yes um so
one of the times when my mom was here I
was gonna take Madden to go sit on
Santa's lap that would be fun to see her
first grandchild sit on Santa's lap and
blah blah blah and you hate holidays
that's the major factor in this argument
or just fact is it factor
I hate weekdays too so I never not once
did I think oh he'll want to be there
he'll want to go to the busy mall he'll
want to stand in line with parents
screaming at screaming children he'll
want to sit on Santa's lap human okay
sit on Santa's lap who he you don't like
qualities you don't like Santa you don't
like the concept you don't like families
and children none
I didn't think for one second that you
wouldn't want to go I'm a de Serre burns
you sure you don't like humans things
the thing is is you get I think a little
bit you want to compensate too much for
how I'm you know I'm just a I'm just a
grump I'm a grouch about everything so
it's just like I'm usually gonna you
know piss and moan and complain about
most things which I'm sure is very
attractive um but it's still like you
know you you instead of just sort of
like yeah I mean almost you just
accepting that that's just the way it's
gonna be your ideal and what I fix
things and I understand you don't
callous to it but you but you don't
um you you still affect you to the point
where you want to fix it I want Madden
to go sit on Santa and have a
Thanksgiving pie to play when she played
in a brighter day we have a Thanksgiving
pie to play in we got some good pictures
but it's do we did it I sent him to my
feeling my echoes did you bake that and
I go no I bought it and I didn't even
buy it to eat we bought it for a photo
shoot
no I mean oh well that took the kids but
out of it pretty good buy um so I took
her to see Santa kind of I we were at
school we saw the Santa head set up and
so she went and sit on his lap but she
wasn't she was wearing play clothes from
school so I didn't actually get her
picture taken I come home to tell you my
mom and I are taking Madden to sit on
Santa's lap in the next day or so
whatever you're all of a sudden we're
like I want to be there Madden see Santa
Bowl what like you took a stance for
Christmas for once and so I was like uh
okay like I didn't want to tell you that
she had already met
so yesterday we go to sit on Santa's lap
and you still didn't know that she had
already met him like that there yeah you
did a great job of keeping things from
me I finally told you because she was so
chill with him she's like hey I know you
I've been through this before I'm like
so proud of her too big strong girl
Oh act they go way back
but I you know I understand that you
think I did and I'm not I'm not faulting
you for not you know realizing that I
you know would feel that way about her
sitting on Santa's lap it was just you
know and like I told you yesterday when
we were gone you know without you
thinking of it I wouldn't even thought
to take her to see Santa cause uh you
know at this point in her life I mean
she's six months old she doesn't know
about that uh it's for our pictures for
the future so she look at all that my
first Christmas and and I I rely on you
to remember stuff like them because I
just don't aim to keep it her of the
memory oh yeah you're the other you're
the historian
um at this point because I'm just trying
to you know get through the next [ __ ]
road trip or whatever and write some
jokes right it's [ __ ] script but III
don't I'm sorry that I introduced her
and mr. Claus what no I'm saying I'm
just I'm going I'm just trying to get
you to like I don't like I said I don't
fault you for wanting to do that without
me or thinking that it wasn't a big deal
to me
and that you could but it was just when
you mentioned it you know I was like oh
uh could you I'd really rather be there
for that I mean
it just seemed like a thing where if
it's her first time on Santa Clauses lap
and I don't know why I mean it's just
sort of like I guess the whole you know
it's engrained in me with tradition and
you know I sat on Santa's lap was a kid
you know and it's an adult a few times
but this was a weird party it's yellow
weed but still I just I did wouldn't you
say when you brought it up I'm like I I
kind of like to be there I mean because
it's a you know the first time I did I
want to be there and I don't know why
and I don't know why you know this out
of you know I can't I can't like really
paint a consistency picture for you and
say see I do this so that's why I said I
wanted to see her on Santa's lap for the
first time no it's just wouldn't that
came up I was like I don't think I want
to be cut out of that and I just cut out
of that's kind of a wrong word you know
I don't I don't want to be not there I
don't want to not be there when she
she's seeing it for the first time and I
don't know why and I'm say I'm sorry I
just I'm glad that you wanted to be
there I want you to be a part of all
those stupid things I just thought you
would think it was a stupid thing and if
I would have brought it to you and said
will you come with us you don't know me
that well okay cuz I don't would not
have gone right tell me everything is
that the scythe never said that in my
life and I I just wouldn't I see the
thing is if we had you asked me I would
have died in this case I would have said
uh you know yeah of course I want to go
it's hard to keep up with you cap it is
I didn't say I'm you know I'm not a head
case I'm a head case but that's it's
again
congratulations on your marriage this is
that this is the guy you got so what day
of the week you want to go meet the
Easter Bunny and now see I'm a user
you're like I you know when you were
telling me that you had taken her to see
I heard you say you see Santa and she
lies that is sorta like guilt like that
you felt that sort of guilt that you had
to tell me once it was once we got in
the pictures and everything taken and it
was over I mean and usually I mean the
consequences of me getting mad about
stuff are pretty slim I've gotten mad
because Madame met Santa for 10 seconds
a week ago like that but the thing is
when I do get mad it's like it's not
really like like oh no better hide Jon's
mad I mean it's like I'm not gonna do
anything but I I just it would yeah
we're like you know I'll make sure that
you're there when she sees the Easter
Bunny and I'm like [ __ ] the Easter Bunny
[ __ ] stupid-ass Easter Bunny it's
like it's like Santa's punk-ass little
brother or something like it is he
doesn't count the [ __ ] bunny hey you
up with you hey I really used to go see
the Easter Bunny I don't I mean we saw
him a few times I guess it's it's yeah
I'm surprised they don't remember that
like more like I don't have more
memories than like like one or two of
seeing Santa or seeing the Easter Bunny
really yeah I don't have that that many
uh my mom has every year
it looks like Santa's [ __ ] in my mom's
house I mean it just gets exploded with
Christmas yeah and maybe shit's not the
word barf I don't know and I mean
there's just Christmas everywhere I mean
the little snowman figurines the
Christmas I mean she's got a thousand
different like Santa Claus fit I don't
she just goes Wow
did that [ __ ] pickle thing no like
Christmas in there Jesus Christ
I've never heard of that anything they
did that that find the pickle it's a
German tradition yeah my mother's maiden
name is lips
burger right which burger wi t ZB er ger
yeah just in case you need my password
my past with anything no it means it
means wits means joke or funny antidote
in burger means Mountain joke on a
mountain people right last names we have
a son his name's gonna be wits like you
know like Luke Skywalker like that's
that's his name that you go oh yeah he's
a badass he's a Skywalker like you know
he's you know but I mean joke on a
mountain like real that that's what
somebody in Germany came up with
it's a mountain full of jokes of a lot
of jokes your son with it means joke and
it's a family anyways where we going
with this a bad sandwich oh so there's
the German tradition where you hide a
small pickle ornament on a tree my
sister and I go at it it's so fun who do
you go at it the poor girl didn't go at
it she just was looking for it College
Apple II she was so honest she didn't
even look for it before we got there I
mean like well yeah she's a little too
honest yeah exactly
she didn't even she didn't look for it
like on the Jews like no I wait till
Jamie gets here and then I'd had that
thing scoped out for months
ah Jesus and I mean that's what was fun
about Easter too was that I mean my
sister and I are 10 years apart so it's
always been like I've wanted to have a
rivalry with her but it's not fun until
like the last couple years when she's
able to like actually take me down
she's like four inches taller than me
and she's straight muscle like she can
she could knock me out if she wanted to
but at that time she was the freshman in
high school maybe when I wouldn't leave
went there that time we bent when I was
25 so yeah she was 15 right so I mean
you just don't you know you could take
her out at that point I think we talked
about fighting my sister okay well I'm
saying cuz you were you guys were we're
competing for the pickle I'm trying to
pull up a clip of because you you found
it of course I did well I mean well of
course cuz you're the yeah you're the
man honey even done it where like my
family usually goes to Fort Myers
Florida for Christmas and the last like
couple years as an adult in college and
stuff I didn't go with them so and my
sister's the only other grandchild child
in the family so they would have her
look for it and then they would have
like my mom or aunt or someone look for
it for me while on the phone and I would
be going look up look down look left
look right look like North West and I
would still win so lame come on man I
want those traditions with Madden like
on 4th of July for breakfast we have
sundaes which I mean I know that we die
screaming most days for breakfast anyway
so it's not really a big woohoo but
still like having those little fun
things to do big fear go-round oh well I
look I I just with the way you won
though like I mean because you like I
didn't I hadn't a first date winner I
mean the first snowfall we makes um
snowballs and then we freeze them and
then the first day of spring we throw
snowballs and have big snowball fight
see you were that's not really a holiday
tradition but that was one of the family
traditions that just popped into my head
yeah I just I just remember I'm trying
to find the clip right now it was you're
playing you're watching bath because it
was it was it was like there's this
clip of like in the 92 finals the Jordan
like he like went coast-to-coast and
like he dunked on like five Knicks and
and and he was so pissed off that game
like he just like he like towered over
the guys after he dunked on him yeah
yeah yeah and it wasn't that's what you
did to that little girl were you I mean
you're 14 year old sister if do you are
you yelled you screamed yeah it was like
it's a pickle you put it's a finger
grown up you don't need presents them
it's not like when you were a kid when
you lived on Christmas I mean it's just
it's just having a sibling ten years
apart we didn't have that cool rivalry
when we were at the age where we could
have a rivalry yeah you yeah you did
it's uh I see it's not on this it 92
finals Michael Jordan dunking on the New
York Knicks it needs to be noted 92
Eastern Conference Center conference
right sorry okay I did not look like
Michael Dorn dunk you did you you you
celebrated and flexed like MJ like I on
a freshman girl in high school like you
yeah hear it like she'd been fouling you
all day like it was like dude what if
the [ __ ] she didn't she didn't do it
things just a pickle it's just a fickle
like you would you it would you win a
[ __ ] the blockbuster gift certificate
or something from that like it was a
Victoria's Secret gift card I wasn't
that far off I wasn't that far off it's
so good um hey cuz he I would be a
general gift that could go to either one
of you
yeah yeah oh sweet pea
just even Milken yeah well she's been
nursing through my loud yelling yeah
she's used to you and Barney Oh
I'm sorry I didn't mean to talk too much
while she was sleeping no she's fine
she's fine she just when she kind of
like is in between awake and sleep she
has this like old lady granny face that
like oh you interrupted money that's my
old granny table music you know we have
probably like 40 different pickle
ornaments cuz after that after you beat
it became such a legend yeah
I bought so many of them just like it's
not even you can't even find one in the
tree now because there's so many of them
it's not a thing anymore thing is I mean
you yeah you're you're somebody it's
like you you want to continue the
traditions that you grew up with as far
as holidays ago but the you can't rely
on me to to either plan them execute
them or I love it yeah even like say
like yeah let's do that like and it just
it's it's like if you weren't like
Maddie to grow up with that stuff it's
you know it's gonna be at least at this
point largely are you because I think
just don't not not only do I I don't
have the the you know I don't have the
time to focus on it mentally I don't
want it so I think you will as you get
older I mean obviously we're not gonna
have a snowball fight the first day of
spring in LA but I do want her to have
those little things and I think even in
the last she just turned six months on
Sunday and as she gets older and starts
being more aware and you guys have a
bond going on that it's okay this is
what I'm getting that with us if Santa
had happened four months ago when she
was two months old and it would
literally been putting a doll into a
stranger's arms you want
wanted to go but because she's now six
months old and she was looking up at him
and smiling and amazed by it all
you were intrigued by it as well and he
wanted to be there for it so the older
that she gets and the more fun she has
you're gonna want to be a part of it I
think you're wrong I mean as far as that
assessment because I mean not not as far
as the second half I mean as far as yes
I I do I do agree that the the potential
for Parenthood and how much like you
know I I just love her and I want to be
a part of her you know everything in her
existence like you are and like you you
want to be a of course I so I'm not just
gonna just say well I'm just gonna be
like this about and whatever holidays or
anything else forever I might very well
change because of her and but I think
that if you had told me that you were
taking her to see Santa like if he like
let's say you were still pregnant and
did like my last week and he said into
your like after you give birth you're
gonna take her to see Santa I would have
been like I whatever it doesn't really
matter but as soon as she came out into
this world I've wanted to be around for
her so I think it's not when she was two
months I was she was two months old she
was you know well into being my sweet
pea so she she's a a no I I think as
soon as I held her for the first time I
I don't think that you became so
obsessed I am I diameter Thalia I
obsessed II with that little girl who
says that beside you what the [ __ ] is
your problem obsessed II of course I
were having a little pathetic problem in
the kitchen a little bit ago me you and
her well it was me and her and you and
Scobie yeah we haven't had a good slow
dance we have one of those
Amazon Prime robot things where you say
Alexa and she turns on and you say what
time is it or set the timer for 5
minutes or play Adele's hello and she
does it like it's kind of cool I like
her you you end up like verbally abusing
or the [ __ ] yeah I think that there's
just I have more music and stuff on my
iTunes and it's just but it's fun that
we have little dance parties in the
kitchen now because we can just say
Alexa play my mama yeah and and we do it
but couldn't do that with an iPad or a
better speaker I mean it's a better
speaker but yeah you can do that with a
lot of not really the direction I was
noting sorry
so you and your daughter were slow
dancing it was really cute she looks so
content against your chest and so you
know I kind of I come to try to break it
up break it in and scooby comes and he's
like puppies he does is like scratch on
my legs where he went to picked up and
so he and I started slow dancing
together and the four of us were just
having our own little prom well Barney
Barney this visitor Barney was the creep
in the shadow brownie
yeah just making sure you kids are safe
I'm gonna have a little whiskey my mom
didn't realize that Scooby likes being
picked up she's always thought it was
something that I did where I was just
like picking up and came around on my
hip like no he asked for it
hey guys I've never seen he look like
really because most dogs like they'll be
they'll accept being picked up like okay
fine for a minute and then they'll start
to like wiggle and go get we put me down
and Sobeys like no he'll put his head on
your shoulder and no he asked for that
yeah yeah he asked to be picked up and
then he he wants to he lays his head on
your shoulder and as I thanked
you for carrying me he's like like
lurking a Roger on American Dad like I
mean it's like it's carry me thank you
I like being carried it's like
fluctuated between 25 and 30 pounds for
the last five six years and I swear he
weighs a trillion pounds now that we
have a 15 pound baby it was like the
numbers though I always say it's like he
stays around he stays around 25 he
doesn't go very high no I mean when I
seen him go way high like even toward ah
I think there was a moment when we lived
here and he was like 20 I love him I'm
sorry I don't I'm just saying that now
that we have a small tiny baby he feels
so heavy yeah he does he does yeah cuz I
mean she's still I mean the difference
between 15 pounds and 25 pounds is big
when you're you know minute when you're
slow dancing like oh yeah when you're
slow dancing and just you know minutes a
minute that you're carrying that you
know sack of a baby or sack of dog you
know it's a it's again it can add up on
your your back your knee arm falls
asleep
or whatever get it together old man a
lot of complaints okay I got bursitis um
so we started this podcast up by talking
about another podcast and about this
podcast do you want to talk about
another podcast
Tommy's podcast oh podcast hashtag
podcast yeah well yeah weird that way
how'd you hear about it well I have an
app on my phone it's Facebook but for a
fan page so like they came to me asking
me if I wanted to be a part of it so
it's not your regular Facebook and it's
not your Facebook fan page it's a
separate one called like mentions or
something it's like black I don't know
but it basically lets me see everything
that I want is so like if anyone types
in John cap rule oh I see it or I have
it also set to like the Comedy Store so
I see if anybody mentions the Comedy
Store it shows me that too even the ones
in England and Austria
the other comedy stores are and then I
Chelsea Lately a couple different like
little trigger words I have that it
shows me what people are saying so with
the Comedy Store one it came up with a
comedian I had never heard of never seen
before Earl Skakel Skakel something like
that oh he had you I I've heard it I
know I've heard his name probably around
the store but I don't I looked at his
picture on the thing and I I don't know
that I've ever talked to him or come
across him I'm not sure that I I don't
think I know him and I kind of thought I
di I mean at least up until the past
maybe a couple of years I just kind of
knew everybody around there so yeah
right well even I thought I would know I
mean dude we've been more out of it in
the last year yes always evolving yeah
well I mean with with you would watch
you got pregnant and then just with my
road schedule and you know I've just you
know we live further away too and it's
just like it's you know what I have a
weekend off or whatever I don't I plus
like well ever since because the reason
why we listen on this podcast was it you
know it was interviewing Tommy Tommy
Morris was the old talent coordinator at
the Comedy Store
yeah he was and our coordinator for I
love Tommy yeah you too I mean he was
when you and I first started dating I
was so intimidated by the Comedy Store
and all the comedians and it was like
just this place that it was a magical
and I didn't feel worthy of being in it
Tommy was someone who really made me
feel like I was welcome there and I was
wanted there mm-hmm and I will always
love him for that just to make me feel
so comfortable that I could go back
there and it not only just be you know
he would let me have whatever seat in
the audience I wanted I was allowed to
like roam the building I can go up on
the roof or in the back and I never felt
like what the [ __ ] is she doing back
here or something you know like he
always made me feel really welcome yeah
so um anyway always in from the start
like with the you know from the time he
he met you he was tell you know he even
said to me like you know he just started
he just thought you were obviously he
didn't see us at home but he's like he's
like you know is that you're the
greatest thing in the world for me and I
knew he really really did you know I
always felt like he really did care
about me
you know not only as an artist as a
person cuz we you know we we basically
we worked together at that place and you
know sort of helped each other you know
do our jobs for a lot of years so he was
he was a Tom Norris was a you know when
you think about like when the you know
five or 10 most important people in your
life you know he would he'd be in there
for me well major yeah we don't normally
listen to podcast and I very rarely do
and you don't at all
and so when this one came up and it was
an interview of Tommy I we were driving
to go see Santa and I was like do you
want to listen to this podcast never had
heard this comedian before but we wanted
to hear what Tommy had to say and yeah
it was what almost a two-hour long
podcast and yeah 99% of it was Tommy
talking that's what Tommy does yeah yeah
I mean you have to really be you know
well you have to be a blabbermouth like
me to be able to actually you know have
you know take the floor or take you know
take the mic from Tommy and go oh wait
now wait here I got [ __ ] to say to and I
mean there were times big personality he
is there were times that we sat in his
office at the Comedy Store in you too I
mean you're both [ __ ] motormouth and
I would literally not she's just sitting
there like my brain just needed to turn
all bad for you to it'd be like three
hours you
long time yeah I mean but you know he
you know listening to that I was um you
know kind of just brought it a lot of
that back up for me about you know him
being gone is that the you know the
Comedy Store was sold
he was unexpectedly fired yeah and
unfairly fired I mean I think he was he
was put out because you know the people
who own the place
decided that you know they wanted to go
in a quote-unquote different direction
which their different direction just
didn't involve somebody like him who was
you know they basically wanted to do you
know all they want to run the whole
place like a business and I'm sorry to
wake her face she was pouting it you
like why that place is basically been
taken over from a business standpoint
it's a it's a you know like every other
comedy club really every other comedy
club
well with the exception of a few you
know there's there did I mean I mean I
get along really well and everything
with the people who run the place now
they're cool guys and everything and but
they're business people I mean that's
really what their their objective is and
developing comics and being you know you
know an artist colony and a safe haven
for artists to develop is not really you
know the main right of major priority
for those guys and you know I'm not
saying that that that makes them bad
people or anything like that it doesn't
it just makes them different and what I
just feel like you know I'm glad when I
heard that podcast that I think you know
people like you know Earl Earl was
somebody who obviously was you know it
would be one of the people who was at
the wrong end of Tommy's wrath as far as
his position and you know him not
letting him they're not not making him
whatever a paid regular at The Comedy
Store and so then people would get mad
at Tommy like who the [ __ ] is he to
judge my talent why doesn't he think I'm
any good and blah blah blah and a lot of
people hated Tommy for you know for you
know for for the really difficult
position he was in
which was you know he sort of you know
he was sort of a figurehead that a lot
of people felt like he held the keys to
their success um you know or failure and
the thing is he didn't because I just
think any all those guys who complained
about him all the time
it was like well where else do you
perform like do you perform at all the
other clubs in town and it's just just
Tommy who doesn't want you on at the
store because it's like it's if if you
can put if you can perform at every
other club then would why are you even
why is even matter to you about the
store I mean cuz it's like it you know
but it's like it's usually guys who who
get spots nowhere anyway and then it's
like well wired all of a sudden that
just fixated on you know oh well Tommy's
keeping my date keeping me down just
like people used to think Mitzi was
keeping him down the difference between
Tommy and Mitzi wasn't Mitzi on the
building and Tommy didn't Tommy was
still an employee so Tommy was it you
know
Tommy could have their there were so
many times over the the years that he
was telling a coordinator that he would
tell me that he he felt like he was he
was
I mean around much longer they were
gonna get rid of them they were trying
to get rid of them and you know so it
was like it was something that was in
the works for a long time it just
happened to go down when it went down
and the reason why they used for it
going down was just you just uh it was
just an official explanation and it was
you know it was it was made up because I
dev that I'm not even gonna get into
that because it's garbage
um but you know the things that you know
I was interested in here and it I guess
um you know Tommy came along like before
he was even officially talent
coordinator and the time that I was at
The Comedy Store I got there and you
know it was a dark time the it was there
was the early 2000s and I mean just the
weeknights were so dead and you know
there we we weren't the Comedy Store was
very slow to embrace you know the the
internet and the you know social media
and [ __ ] like that as it came along and
and so you know they're just the the
ticket sales and crowd numbers
everything suffered and the vibe there
was just it was it was hard it was a
rough place when I got there but um I I
just remember feeling so sort of um I
guess they you know I I just felt like
my outlook was so bleak at the time when
I was struggling to get spots at the
store because mitzi hardly ever came in
and when she did come in she was in a
[ __ ] bad mood and she was firing
people and you know it just was a just a
rough and then you know I mean he had
the the the guys like they talked about
on that podcast you know dominating all
the stay a stage time you know you know
any Griffin I love Eddie Griffin because
he were
did help me out at a time when I really
needed help in my career and he's a
really good guy as far as just being a
you know he cares about the artform and
he really he did me a solid when he had
no reason to cuz I really don't even
think he even knows my name
he just had seen me on stage and thought
that I was i I deserved a shot and and
held me up but back at that time there
was nobody really running the place and
Eddie would come in and man he bumped
the whole lineup for hours
I knew hours in four hours three hours
we just be there all night waiting for
him I mean he was essentially like
talking to one girl in the front row
smoking a cigarette like it and
everybody was just like is this the show
and I mean he we had nobody really
protecting us as far as artists who who
needed that stage to develop who wanted
to you know you know who who had become
paid regulars but were you know sort of
being pushed around and so Tommy came in
and you know he had a he had a
background in running you know
nightclubs or whatever in Florida but he
was uh he was an artist at heart so it
was really really fantastic combination
because it was like a guy who he you
know as he went along in that job he was
like he was expressing himself through
talent there's a talent coordinator
position instead of just being a guy who
made out a list every night you know
you're at 9:15 you're at 9:30 urine
seems like a DJ for comedians what and
he actually like he would always you'd
call me and he'd be so excited about you
know the lineup that he made you know
he'd be like see here's what I got like
I mean it that they did it you know they
call you now and it's just like yeah
here on at 10:45 and that's it it when
he was he was like okay still this so
the way I got it going
is we I have so-and-so at 10 and then 10
15 no we're gonna do this at 10:30 and
then you come in at 10:45 do whatever it
is just like he had this he understood
the comedians in the comedy and the
peaks and valleys of how the show would
flow yeah and he gave a [ __ ] that's so
thick such a big [ __ ] deal
he gave a [ __ ] about that place he cared
and he didn't own the place like Mitzi
did but he cared about it like he did
and um I was glad to kind of get the
impression from Earl's interview with
them that you know I that they you know
that there was he was it was almost like
time had gone by and and tempers had
simmered down and people were starting
to realize what an asset he was to the
comedy world I mean cuz I I've been you
know ever since I've tried to keep in
contact with Tommy you know through
email and stuff like that and it's you
know I even said to him and one of them
I was the you know it's it was so easy
to keep in touch with him when he was at
the Comedy Store like I you know I don't
call in as much anymore when I'm home
and I know it wouldn't be like that if
he was there because if he was there I
would feel like you know I would tell
him you know when I when I had to go on
the road for say three weeks or
something I'd be like I gotta go on a
road for three weeks but I promise I'll
be back you know at this time and I felt
like it was almost like you know I owed
him as much as I wanted to go there and
do a spot because I cared about the club
that tommy was running and Tommy who was
trying to because he really did the dark
place that I I came upon when I was a
doorman at the Comedy Store Tommy turned
that place by by leading out a lot of
the negativity that was at that place
and by putting the passion in that he
had
by you know really really young mitzi he
was the first person that I had ever
seen that mitzi like allowed to sort of
get inside her head and and and you know
take a tour and he cared anyway so he
was like he really wanted to do what she
did and because she really really did
create a unique and wonderful place for
the comedy world which is the Comedy
Store it's like no other and and it was
just he was just kind of rotting at the
time when he got there because she was
ill and she wasn't around as much and
there was nobody really run on the place
and he got there and gradually took the
reins from her as far as doing her job
but the problem was is he didn't he
didn't own the place but he you know I I
just as far as Tommy Morris himself I
mean it you know I was thinking about
actually calling him tonight after heat
yeah I don't know if I will because I'm
gonna talk tout again but uh it's a hey
you know hey he's just somebody that I
will always you know I always have a lot
of gratitude toward him and I thank him
because I thank Mitzi shore for what she
did and and and and recognizing me as a
talent and and giving me a place to grow
but I really felt that my outlook was
bleak when I was a doorman because I
just felt like Mitzi never comes in and
nobody ever nobody ever sees like when I
when I did well and I would go on a
stage and I would do you know I felt
like I you know I was a you know I
caught a fall out set or something like
that and I felt like I was you know
better than most of the lineup and
nobody was there to see that and I felt
like well what it was it was
discouraging
but then Tommy became that guy who was
like he saw what was going on every
night so everybody who was doing really
well you know he would report back to
Mitchie and say you know you really need
to you know start giving this guy more
spots or so-and-so it's doing really
well or so-and-so's you know dragging
the place down I know they're you know
they've been there for years but they
they gotta go and he did that and did
that opened the door for me and a lot of
the other guys he mentioned on there too
to turn that place back into what it was
which was a which was a place where
rising young aggressive voices and
comedy could flourish so that's why you
know they've mentioned that thing about
Carlos with me and you know and I'm cool
with Carlos as far as a person you know
and I've never had any problem with him
personally but I it would I always hated
the idea of you know I'd have to do it
when I was younger I hated having to
[ __ ] sit there like if I got bumped
by a you know somebody who was a bigger
comic than I am and we have to sit there
and wait to go on and not know when the
[ __ ] I was going on because I get really
anxious before I go onstage so it's just
it's torture for me to sit there go yeah
[ __ ] he's not done yet okay yeah it's
still not done all right and and I
remember the last straw was yeah you
know the sound guy had put it Tommy was
gone and say and the sound guy put
Carlos on in front of me even though you
know the place was we had a pretty full
room that night I don't know if he was
sold out but it was close and that
wasn't because of Carlos because he
wasn't on the lineup that was because of
you know the promotions that they
did and because of you know the names of
me and the guys you know you know all
the other people who were on there we
had built a following ourselves around
town and so we were the draw and we had
filled that room and I got bumped by
Carlos because the sound guy just felt
like well that's what you're supposed to
do cuz that's what we always used to do
and I said to Carlos I said dude what
how much how much time are you gonna do
and he was like irritated that I was
even asking him and then he just said
look I'm just I'm just gonna do 20
nights where I'm just gonna do 20 I'm
done what year was this this was 2000
yeah
between two thousand five two thousand
in 2007 maybe um yeah very around 2000
yeah somewhere in there 2005 to 2007 uh
and if you probably owe seven probably
closer to that and anyway
India he so he he said he was gonna do
20 and I waited around in the backstage
just seething and pacing and just
waiting for him to get the [ __ ] off and
I waited I get he got I got 235 and I
was like you know what [ __ ] this this is
just disrespectful and I couldn't do
that to somebody
I just wouldn't I wouldn't I couldn't
enjoy my set knowing somebody was back
there hating me for wasting their entire
night and [ __ ] them over out of their
time and I wouldn't do that to him and
you know and there are a lot of people
who are you know Chris Rock in
particular I remember he he wouldn't do
that to guys like he you know there are
guys who actually do care about the
other comics and are considerate of
other people's you know a place and III
just was like I'm not I look I can't
off him from bumping me but what I can
do is I can I can leave I don't have to
stay here and I don't need I don't
desperately need the stage time anymore
because I was getting enough at that
point so I was like you know what [ __ ]
this I'm walking and they can deal with
whoever you know whoever came to see me
and didn't get to see me which ended up
being quite a few people I guess they
had to give them you know free tickets
to come back and I was like it I mean so
I I just I wasn't trying to like really
I wasn't trying to make any sort of
power play I just was exercising my own
freedom which was you know because I
didn't want to deal with my own head you
know having to wait to go onstage
because some rude ass was [ __ ]
running the light so I just I just left
and what it end up happen is you know
they instituted new rules and made that
dude you know abide by some sort of code
that you know he wasn't allowed to just
come in and bump everybody and if he did
he was gonna have to wait until Tommy
said and that's why it was so valuable
about having somebody who was sort of
the alpha dog at the places that Tommy
was it wasn't taking any [ __ ] and he
was protecting guys like me and so you
know I just really you know I I can't I
can't there's no way I can ever thank
the guy enough I wish he had I wish he
owned his own Club
I really do I you know if I if I could
help them do that I would I'd you know
why you can't have but I understand
having a business to make money and why
you'd want a business person to be there
but why can't you have an artist helping
the artist feel like you know what I
mean like why can't you have a mixture
of both hey why did he have to go I
think because um they maybe wanted their
free reign to
books of what they wanted to book and
not deal with you know you know like a
lot of times there that system there
didn't make sense to people like there
remember one time like noir McDonald
wanted to go on and then which they
called Mitzi at night and she's like no
because you didn't know who he was or
whatever and they're like it's Norma
Donald we talk and you know they just
ended up like putting him on anyway but
it was like you know she had sort of
that's sort of it's a Members Only place
and it's a place that's like look once
you get pet and you get your but that's
what makes it so cool right
but the thing is is that quite not
having that it turns it into every other
place but I think that can that can
maybe counter your you know your your
business plan because of you know to be
honestly I go there and it's um you know
and when I go there now it is the place
is uh you know pretty packed um a lot of
times and that's you know that's a large
part because of what Tommy did to bring
it back but it's also you know there's a
lot of I'm sure you know a business
moves that are being made that might not
have been a there might have been made
difficult by somebody like Tommy who's
like no we can't you know that guy
didn't go through the proper channels to
showcase or whatever you know it looks
like but but he's a celebrity when it's
like what do you just I don't know I I
just think and plus they're just been I
think years of baggage build-up between
you know Tommy and the shores and
everything that your her sons you know I
think they just kind of were done with
that relationship and and it's not like
Tommy had Tommy didn't have yeah I
remember Tommy telling me what's the
mitzi wish she said that she wished she
could leave the place to him and and you
know obviously she couldn't but
you know it was like he you know I I
don't think like you know you Polly's an
artist unto himself like he he said it's
a comic he wants to do his thing and
doesn't really want to worry about other
people thing that much you know it might
change over time as he gets older but
then there's other brothers or
businessman you know they're just not
gonna look at they're just not gonna do
what Tommy was willing to do he just
really it's a rare bird that is going to
want to do what he did and he deserves a
lot of credit and not just from me
because of you know because I was able
to flourish under it a lot of people uh
and and most of us comics who who go to
that place i I just
and and then yeah if the other thing I
do just from that with a podcast
interview was just like when they were
talking about like why did I get they
there's always a [ __ ] grumblings from
the you know which you know as a comic
you have to eventually block out which
you get into comedy and you start to you
you get this impression that this is a
team sport and that we're all kind of
buddies and we were a big fraternity and
we're all here for each other
and it's all [ __ ] cuz they're you
know it's not football it's [ __ ]
tennis I mean it's uh it's it's a it's a
it's a single sport it's not a something
that so they're not gonna you know is
there's people who are you know getting
more spots more stage time that you're
expensed you they do they're not gonna
you know stick up for you and say hey
let him take some of my stage time they
you know we all moved from wherever to
Los Angeles the you know to to chase a
dream and that dream doesn't involve you
know finding more [ __ ]
I mean in that and I say that and I know
that sounds cold and I'm not it's like
The Bachelor I'm not here to make
friends it's it's not like The Bachelor
um it's uh I don't I don't ever want it
because the thing is is it bothered me
because I I you know I've always thought
that I've I've always been respectful to
other people and anybody I've dealt with
I've always been respectful toward I
know that I'm very very anxious and
agitated before I go onstage so there
may have their of all there have
definitely been times when you know
people have caught me at the wrong
moment before I go onstage because I'm
actually you know I'm nervous you know
about whatever I'm gonna do or you know
it's like I don't want to fail I want to
do really well and I wanna you know yeah
I just I cared about what I was doing
much like Tommy did and so I don't know
whatever the implications were that they
you know what it means to Tommy never
would tell me um you know very well is
so-and-so you know heard there are
certain people who don't you know who
don't like me for some reason and you
know there's certain people who just who
decide to compensate for their you know
maybe for their lack of talent by by
tonin uh you know turning art into a
[ __ ] you prison yard but it's not
that you know I mean you know there's
guys out there who are in this who are
in the art business who were no more
than just [ __ ] bullies and they're
you know because it's easy to bully
artists because most of us are pretty
[ __ ] passive so you know yeah they
they flourished because they're the only
the only bullies around and you know
it's like fine you're I mean you're
you're you're the toughest guy at the in
the
back of the Comedy Store and you said
I'm still funnier than you are um so
deal with that stupid um but that's not
really why I just it just always I've
just always been like you know what it
always bothered me that there'd be some
sort of resentment or whatever like I
got right after I did meet cap I did
I asked Tommy cuz Joe Rogan wasn't
coming around anymore because of the
Carlos thing and all that [ __ ] Joe Rogan
used to have a half-hour spot on
Saturdays so I'm like you know what
Tommy do it since Rome's not doing that
anymore do you think I could come in and
do double spots in the OL are on
Saturdays to because I want to try to
work out some new stuff you know since
I've already put out a special and I
want to work on a new one
and you know Tommy was not only the
talent quart of music he was a you know
he was a supporter of mine he was a fan
of mine he was largely you know
responsible for where I got it that
place like I said so he gladly gave me
that extra you know that extra 15
minutes or whatever on Saturdays in the
o.r now they didn't last for a real long
time and they and like he said any time
he said that you know I just have too
many guys that I got to put on is it
okay if I just give you the regular
15-minute spot which is fine you know
fine and I mean I never objected I never
it got mad about it and then you know it
you know it Tommy and I always had this
thing where it was like I mean you're
supposed to do with 15 minutes pot at
the store I most of the time I would
come in thinking I'm not a I'm not a
great mood tonight I'm gonna bomb just
lightly at 12 minutes like you do with
everybody else Tommy because I just I
can only do 15 because I might end up
sucking because that's what I felt like
every night and and Tommy would just
kind of look at me like yeah all right
yeah I'll do I'll get Shelby here we are
like he just it always be like oh yeah
okay but then Tommy would lightly at
fifteen minutes at least maybe 18 I mean
he was just Tommy wanted for whatever
reason well I know for what reason
because he felt like the the show got
better because I added something to it
and I don't and I hate even implying
anything like that like did that sounds
arrogant or anything but I feel like you
know I do my job pretty well because I
give a [ __ ] about it and I so so maybe
it's just because you know um you know
I'm I'm decent at what I do that I got
the you know I guess I got some I got
some bonus I guess bonus the bonus
minutes or what whatever but it's not
like I didn't [ __ ] or in those
minutes oh yeah yeah I was I was at that
place for a long time there was a long
time when I was was was as good as
anybody on the lineup and I was I didn't
have a spot so I had to wait on the
fallout list or I had to work the door
for seven eight nine nights in a row and
and hang the [ __ ] letters on the sign
for some comics who weren't who weren't
as funny as I was I thought you know I
had to do that in order to you know pay
my dues and earned the spots that I got
so yeah I did go through a time where I
got 30 minute spots on Saturday you know
when it was you know feasible for them
you know and and yeah Tommy you know
Tommy was a you know he he was he was a
guy who I could he was a friend and he
somebody I could go and talk to and say
I need this extra time because he wanted
me to do that extra time too he was a he
was a supporter and I don't I don't feel
like I was given that time I don't
understand why anybody who was there
while I was there would ever question
why I got that time I mean it's good I I
don't know really I mean me I if I mean
there's just certain guys out there who
not only are talented but who who put
the work in and I was both of those
things so if you've got a problem with
anytime I've ever put in at that place
or any place you can [ __ ] suck it all
right you really can I mean and I'm not
gonna beat you up because I'm not a
bully
alright so you know what you can kick my
ass too over these comments I don't care
but still but still what I mean I'll go
on stage swollen I'll be [ __ ] funnier
than you are so alright so uh I yeah
enjoy that III yeah that's that's my
piece on that whole thing you you sweep
the air you blah I'm sorry I've been
rambling myself James been trying to add
in when she can cuz if somebody's uh at
the witching hour now time for bed
yeah it's uh it's almost 6:00 that's our
life at this point our life your life
right say yeah trying to be you know I
see a team player here well oh yeah next
week you'll be home it'll be our life
but then you're heading to Lexington and
then Tempe and Baltimore you're doing a
casino in Baltimore the Horseshoe Casino
uh-huh so yeah those will be yeah I'll
probably be reasonably funny in those
shows
because I put the time in the work in
and I had I think some talent to begin
with I hate talking like this cuz I well
it's not you you're not a promoter you
don't know I don't you don't promote my
own podcast yes I know I know yelling
for it but it is irritating when you
listen I mean we just listen to that
podcast just because oh it's something
that Tommy's on and Tommy's still
interviewing me when I wasn't when I
wasn't talking to write most of the
things that Tommy all the things that
Tommy said or things that we've heard
before
yeah I almost felt like he told me that
just to Bruce boost my ego really right
where where you stemmed off on this
conversation rant whatever was because
in a part of that podcast you know they
were saying well whatever you think
about cap as though people talk [ __ ] in
because I'm in the back corners of
social media I do see a couple of older
comics talk [ __ ] and I don't know why
because you are the nicest guy I've ever
met and I'm not just saying that because
I'm your wife I married you because
you're the nicest guy right but and so
it is it's I've even like asked people
and stuff like what I mean where is this
coming from because it seemed so out of
like not even left field like a left her
left like a parking lot filled right and
I think the two that you're talking
about are complete absolutely despise
and I think one one I know that I've
just I've had run-ins with him you know
just and and they've all been I and I I
mean I can say this was all it you know
honesty because of him
I mean they've all been his sort of like
he started fights with me out of nowhere
like where he's he's like sort of like
interpreted conversations or incidents
that you know over DM stage time over
you know whatever like you know who's
going on next type of [ __ ]
that I I've never been anything but
respectful because he was a he was a guy
that I I mean I I looked up to and was I
was a fan of as a kid I I came to know
him as an adult and had much less
respect for him but I mean it was he was
still a guy that like you know I mean
still I have enough respect that I'm not
gonna name his name at this point
because I don't I think I just don't I
don't think you should do that and I
don't think it's your name in one of his
podcast which is where I had first heard
of this because I'm like where did this
come from and even his fans were asking
well what did John Carrillo do and he
couldn't answer it it was like he has
this weird beef like a but I think
that's dead also don't even exist I said
to Tommy once I said you know you kind
of as wonderful as you know of an asset
to the comedy store and and to to me
personally and my quest as you've been
yet kind of hung off target on my back
like cuz Tommy saying things like I'm
the best and you know whether that came
from it see or just from him I don't
know it you know he treated me like I
was yeah it came from mitzi because it's
not only come from Tommy but he he for
whatever you know he thought because of
the way crowds reacted when they were
leaving the people who were repeat
customers the people who what the kind
you know he'd always say that they
talked about you know they usually just
they would like the guy in the head or
whatever it was and it was like I just
you know I bet he he kind of put me out
like almost like like you know a
teacher's pet situation where it's like
you know I was you know sort of like you
know the a favored guy I was I was put
in a favorite situation with him and I'm
put in the situation among
you know a bunch of other comics who you
know you know whether I'm friendly with
most of them and I I mean it's it's but
there is there are jealousies there are
there's competitiveness I'm competitive
as [ __ ] especially in that situation so
I can't find the pickle and dunk all
over my little sister um but I just I
just think he put me in a situation
where was like guys like the guys you're
talking about
they started look like if they were
looking for somebody to resent and two
to hate and to be jealous of they're
gonna look at it's somebody like in my
position when it you know during the
years its Comedy Store with Tommy and
I'm not saying that I'm like in the
comedy world I'm like the you know
anywhere near the top but I'm saying
just at that place at that time
you know I because you also have to
understand comics are generally and
myself included we're not wired very you
know tightly so you know you're you're
amongst jealous competitive nuts and
those jealous competitive nuts are gonna
be mad at whoever gets the treatment
that they want to get they feel like
they deserve themselves and I guess I
got that for a while and so I'm at the
did I catch hell for it but not not
usually to my face because it's usually
I'm usually I usually I just don't I
don't stir up [ __ ] with people I try to
be a decent guy but I'm trying to be a
decent guy in a place that's not
altogether decent people are people are
dicks at times and those two people that
you're talking about
they're just they're just they're waste
of time but they taking hey they can
enjoy Glenn and [ __ ] themselves so I
don't care about I mean I like I said I
could you know I could spell that one
out like I did with Vince Vaughn but I'm
not gonna cuz I just there'd it's just
not worth that we're calling them out
because it'd be like I'm I'd basically
be feeding the fire that they would want
to start which is let's start up a
[ __ ] you know war like like rappers
and I'm not gonna do it because I don't
want them to get you know I don't want
them to get there they're just not gonna
get the publicity that they would want
from me and vice versa
I don't want publicity for [ __ ]
battling other comics I don't give a
[ __ ] about them I'm trying to just just
trying to put my heart out there and I'm
trying to do my own thing trying to you
know you know set my own place in comedy
world and that has nothing to do with
them anymore so you know welcome
but again as never anything but you you
use you know up front decent and honest
with those people and they didn't
reciprocate
[ __ ] them so it is what it is
anyway I'll be in Tempe from the yeah
you already you made the announcement
right what the with where I'm gonna be
yeah and and then we've gone an hour and
32 minutes so that's exactly what we
wanted to do let's uh let's go deal with
this crying baby alright gonna hate